I look back at our favorite auditions
this season on America's Got Talent
so far everybody this is the daily denne
denne and I'm doing things a little
different today because tonight isn't
all new America's Got Talent and let's
be honest this season has been led there
has already been so many memorable
auditions that I thought it was only
appropriate to relive some of our
favorite AGT auditions so far what's
your name
Connie who can forget 13 year old
Courtney hadwin who hit the stage as shy
as you'd expect any young teen about to
perform in front of America that is
until she unleashed her inner Janis
Joplin
judges were floored and her audition has
already racked up over 27 million views
and Counting on YouTube
it's no wonder how he set her straight
to the live show
I'm still not over Courtney's insane
performance but you know that's classic
AGT the axe that hit the stage aren't
always what you expect case in point
Michael Ketterer pediatric mental health
nurse audition for a GT to inspire his
six kids including five foster children
and I think he did just that I mean what
was going on in your head when he hit
that button it was like I went from
being that place of nervous to just pure
joy and just being overwhelmed when he
hit that buzzer it was one of the
greatest feelings I've ever felt
long before marrying his high school
sweetheart Ivey America's Got Talent
contestant pediatric nurse michael
Ketterer grew up singing in church you
start realizing other things that kind
of mean more to you than even your your
greatest dreams and I think to me it was
being able to adopt these children and
being able to impact the lives of
children not spin you around okay I
think we're the best team I can tell
yeah I couldn't do it without her
Michael and Ivy decided to pursue
adoption when their daughter Sophie was
six and asked for brothers the couple
went on to adopt five boys from foster
care starting with brothers Jared Chase
ed your I next came Sean who at one
point was homeless on the streets did
you guys have fun being up backstage at
America's Got Talent and meeting Tyra
Banks she's so pretty right then a call
they never expected to get meet Rodrigo
affectionately known as rowdy rod it's
your turn you're up man the
nine-year-old suffers from cerebral
palsy and despite his bright smile Roddy
never was able to communicate until he
met his new family when we first got him
he he couldn't talk because he was
shaking infants so he was abused by his
caregiver and that's what what gave him
cerebral palsy prior to that he was
totally moved but once we got him
because he couldn't speak
he loved to hear the music and he loved
to feel the rhythms of the music so yeah
so I would spend a lot of my time with
him communicating basically with him
through song
[Music]
[Applause]
he is amazing and I literally asked
Michael and his wife if they could adopt
me their family is that beautiful all
right the next time we'll get to hear
Michael seeing is when the live shows
start on August 14th and that's where
you'll also see Mel B's golden buzzer 15
year-old Amanda Mina
[Music]
walking back to that moment what was
going through your mind when mal reached
over and hit that golden buzzer I really
couldn't believe it like I I kind of
blacked out for a second I was like what
is happening it was real life that was
just incredible what do you think it is
about you that she connected to the most
fairly here I think we both believe in
the same similar thing like empowerment
for young women amanda says she was
bullied when she was younger and hopes
her music inspires kids just like her I
got made fun of a lot that really hurt
if you could say anything to your
bullies now what would you say I don't
wanna say thank you cuz they taught me a
lot and the experiences that I had
before right now I can deal with it
better there's a lot of girls that don't
feel good about themselves and don't
feel beautiful and so I want to put in
my music things that inspire them to
believe that they are amazing
[Music]
natural
[Music]
she's my golden buzzer she's gonna win
the whole thing
you know Amanda isn't the only inspiring
young person to grace that AGT stage
with their talents 14 year old rapper
Flo Jay Lula Simon and the rest of the
judges on a GT with her original song
about gun violence the Georgia native
moved on to the next round but as I
found out her audition was about more
than just competing she had an important
message to share if he would have put
that gun down then he would have been
here right now
and if he would have put that gun down
then she would have been here right now
you're only 14 and yet you come out
there with an original song by the way
with a really really powerful message
what were you hoping people took away
from your performance I just hope people
you know they understand that you can
you can handle situations different like
you don't have to you don't have to you
know in the situation with guns or you
don't have to in the situation with
killing people because people who are
dying like left and right you know what
I mean so you know to have been witness
that in my life that my dad died and he
was shot and he was murdered you know
that affects me you know when I need a
father figure in my life you know and
you know it's kind of scary you know
school shooting you know school
shootings in churches you know it's it's
big it's really scary at a point where
it's like oh my god what's going on
because it's something that affects
everybody no matter what age you are
yeah and sadly it's a reality for a lot
of young people right now there's name
yeah it is because a rapper
x-x-x he just died like and that like
stunned me like that hit me it is like
oh my god yeah I was like are you
serious like is this like Roo and
everybody I didn't even know until like
somebody was tagging me they were like
[ __ ] classified look at this and they
were like and they and I just I just
posted it and I was like hashtag guns
down yeah like he spread that message
people will start to understand that you
know just put the guns down plage J is
wise beyond her years and she could spit
too but you know it's not just about
musical acts on America's Got Talent
only this show also features
death-defying and
blowing stunts there was duo transcend
the married couple with their dangerous
trapeze act
West P the naked man who attempted a
teacup and tablecloth trick
and my personal favorite front pictures
and they're out of this world projection
act
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
crazy right can you tell I love this
show well listen there is still one
golden buzzer left for this first round
of auditions so these are gonna be you
have to find out when AGT airs Tuesday
nights on NBC
until then tomorrow another AGT act us
the duo is here for a live version of
daily Denny so be sure to come back here
at 12 p.m. Pacific 3 p.m. Eastern and
I'll see you guys then
alright bye
[Music]